[Musique]
avez vous entendu parler de la dernière
alerte qui touchent des téléphones
cellulaires les téléphones cellulaires
que vous pensez acheter alors que
voulait louer regardez cet appareil le
prix
1440 dollars mais on vous l'offre moins
cher en 24 mensualités grâce à un rabais
de 420 dollars mais un instant est ce
vraiment un rabais parce que si vous
décrypter les petits caractères vous
allez comprendre qu'après deux ans ce
téléphone n'est pas à vous si vous
voulez le garder il vous reste 420
dollars à payer donc le rabais du départ
sans vos poubelles si vous ne voulez pas
les payer vous devrez rendre le petit
bijou c'est la nouvelle tendance chez
les fournisseurs avec des noms comme
option retour crédit retour ou voie
express ça ne vous fait pas penser
quelque chose eh oui la location de
voiture vous vous pavaner avec le modèle
dernier cri en payant un peu moins cher
que si vous aviez vraiment acheté
l'appareil mais il faut payer le
résiduel après deux ans ou rendre la
pareille et en bon état de marche s'il
vous plaît alors si on vous propose des
mensualités et passe avec les mots
option retour crédit retour ou voie
express c'est de la location passé le
monde
[Musique]